for the first time we're hearing a
public plea for help from a pair of
American siblings trapped in China in a
video you'll see only on CBS this
morning
Cynthia Liu describes the terrifying
experience for her and her brother
Victor they traveled to China last year
but have not been allowed to return home
to the US because of a so-called
exit ban China's government did not
respond to a request for a comment the
State Department warned Americans about
China's exit bans in January senior
foreign affairs correspondent and Face
the Nation moderator Margot Brennan is
at the State Department Margaret good
morning good morning to you Nora
well the Trump administration's National
Security Council spokesperson told CBS
News Chinese authorities have given no
legitimate explanation for refusing to
allow Cynthia and Victor Liu to return
to the u.s. they traveled to China to
visit their dying grandmother and now in
this video you're about to see which was
recorded this week secretly by Cynthia
it's a desperate plea you've done
nothing wrong and we need to go home for
nearly a year Cynthia Liu has been
trapped in China we wake up every
morning terrified the 27 year old
American who works for New York
consulting firm and her brother Victor a
19 year old Georgetown undergrad are
desperate to return home to the US but
their lawyer David Pressman says Chinese
authorities won't let them leave the
country so what happens when Cynthia and
Victor try to go to the airport and get
on a plane back home each time when they
present themselves at the border they
are taken to a room and then they are
ultimately told that they're not allowed
to leave Victor barely understands the
language I mean it's the wildering it's
difficult it's stressful the siblings
are stuck in China under what is known
as an exit ban a tactic used by Beijing
that allows foreigners to move around
the country but prevents them from
leaving it even though the Liu's
siblings are not accused of wrongdoing
exit bans can last days or years we feel
trapped we live with constant distress
because this is not our home we're not
here at batch ways but they're estranged
father Liu
Jiang Ming happens to be one of China's
most wanted fugitives a former executive
at a state-owned Bank Lu is linked to a
1.4 billion dollar fraud case and fled
the country in 2007 the interest of the
Chinese authorities in Victor in Cynthia
is purely to use Victor in Cynthia to
try and get this guy to return to China
their bait they're a form of human bait
Cynthia Liu insists she is powerless
this man abandoned my family many years
ago we are not in touch with him nor do
we have any way of contacting him in
recent years Chinese President Xi
Jinping has led a heavy-handed crackdown
on corruption and family members of the
accused are often treated as if they
were tied to the illegal acts it is just
one of China's many human rights
violations documented by the State
Department and balancing concern about
those against Beijing's heavy economic
influence is getting increasingly
difficult
it's an authoritarian regime that's
integrated economically into the West in
ways the Soviet Union never was national
security adviser John Bolton's call last
year to release the Lu's went unheeded
they now hope their plight will be
raised with top Chinese officials in
Washington this week for trade talks I
have told Victor again again that no
matter how dark our lives can be we need
to hold on to hope now adding to their
distress is the fact that the children
haven't been able to see or speak with
their mother she is imprisoned
she is also a US citizen as for Cynthia
and Victor the State Department says
they're concerned and they remain in
contact Gayle Marga that's a very
complicated story thank you very much